[音樂] 你是否曾經在調查一起事件的過程中，警報不斷堆積，隊友不斷要求更新信息，而你卻沒有足夠的時間來理清所有事情？
在安保行動中，延誤的代價是實實在在的。漏診、分診不完整、決策缺乏完整背景資訊。本學習路徑旨在協助您將混亂轉化為清晰，向您展示 Microsoft Security Copilot 及其內建體驗如何加速調查並提高回應品質。
您好，歡迎光臨。很高興你能加入我們。
我是讓-弗朗索瓦，一名微軟技術培訓師。
本次課程我們將介紹如何使用微軟安全營運平台防禦網路威脅。作為學習路徑二的一部分，讓我們開始學習 Microsoft Security Copilot。
以下是本次學習路徑的議程。我們將從生成式人工智慧的基礎知識入手，因為它是當今副駕駛系統背後的引擎。接下來，我們將介紹 Microsoft Security Copilot 的功能、用途以及重要性。接下來，我們將探討 Copilot 的功能如何直接體現在 Microsoft 安全產品。最後，我們將介紹 Microsoft Defender 中的 Security Copilot 代理，它可以幫助自動化和加速常見的 SOC 任務。
要更好地使用 Security Copilot，了解生成式人工智慧的基本原理會有所幫助。
接下來，我們將轉向基礎知識，探討生成式人工智慧是什麼、大型語言模型的作用、Azure Open AI 的定位、Copilot 在實踐中的意義，以及快速工程如何幫助您獲得更好的結果。
在本模組中，我們將探討大型語言模型（通常稱為 LLM）如何使 AI 應用和服務能夠從自然語言輸入產生原創內容。我們也將把這個想法與人工智慧輔助駕駛技術的出現聯繫起來，該技術旨在幫助人類完成創造性和分析性任務。
在本模組結束時，您將能夠描述什麼是生成式人工智慧、什麼是大型語言模型、什麼是 Azure Open AI、什麼是 Copilots，以及如何使用提示工程來改善生成式人工智慧的回應。
我們將把這些都視為建置模組，然後在本次課程的後續部分，您將看到它們如何直接對應到實際的安全工作流程中。
我們先來區分兩個相關的概念：人工智慧和生成式人工智慧。
人工智慧透過機器學習模仿人類行為，與環境互動並執行任務，而無需明確告知其確切的輸出結果。
生成式人工智慧是一種能夠創造原創內容的特定類型的人工智慧。這是許多現代聊天應用程式的運作原理。
生成式人工智慧應用程式接收自然語言輸入，並以不同格式回傳回應。
一種常見的格式是自然語言生成。
例如，你可能會問：「請給我三個包含辣椒的健康早餐食譜。」並收到明確的書面答案。
另一種格式是圖像生成，例如，創建一張大象吃漢堡的圖片之類的請求可以生成一張新圖片。
第三種形式是程式碼生成，你可能會問：「請教我如何用 Python 編寫一個井字棋遊戲。」該工具會生成初始程式碼，您可以對其進行完善。
這類應用的一個流行例子是聊天機器人 GPT，它是由 OpenAI 創建的聊天機器人，OpenAI 是一家與微軟密切合作的人工智慧研究公司。
關鍵在於，生成式人工智慧不僅僅是自動化，它是由語言理解驅動的內容創作。
生成式人工智慧應用由大型語言模型（LLM）驅動。這些是專為自然語言處理任務設計的專門機器學習模型。這包括確定文本的情感或更廣泛地對文本進行分類、總結文本、比較多個文本來源的語義相似性以及生成新的自然語言。儘管 LLM 背後的數學原理可能很複雜，但對 LLM 的建構和使用方式有一個基本的概念性理解，更容易理解為什麼副駕駛如此有用，以及為什麼你提問的方式會對輸出品質產生直接影響。
現在，讓我們將這些模型連接到許多組織部署它們的雲端平台。
Azure OpenAI 服務是微軟的雲端解決方案，用於部署、客製化和託管大型語言模式。
它將 OpenAI 模型和 API 與 Azure 提供的安全性、可擴充性和治理功能結合在一起。
Azure OpenAI 服務包括預先訓練的生成式 AI 模型、自訂功能、用於偵測和緩解有害用例的內建工具，因此您可以負責任地實作 AI。
以及企業級安全功能，例如基於角色的存取控制 (RBAC) 和對專用網路的支援。
在開發方面，您可以使用 Azure AI Foundry、REST API 支援的 SDK 或 Azure CLI 來建立解決方案。
Azure OpenAI 支援多種使用場景，以滿足不同的需求。
GPT-4 模型是最新一代的自然語言處理與程式碼補全模型。 GPT-3.5 模型（如 GPT-3.5 Turbo）針對基於聊天的互動進行了最佳化，並且可以與許多生成式 AI 解決方案很好地配合使用。
嵌入模型將文字轉換為數值向量，這有助於進行語言分析任務，例如比較文字的相似性。
最後，我們還有 DALL-E 模型，該模型用於根據自然語言提示生成圖像。
開發人員可以在 Azure AI Studio 中使用這些模型，這是一個基於 Web 的環境，您可以在其中部署、測試和管理用於生成式 AI 應用部署的模型。
在這裡，您可以在聊天遊樂場進行實驗，提供少量範例，並驗證模型行為是否符合您的應用程式的需求。
大型語言模型的出現催生了一種新的計算類別，通常被稱為副駕駛。
副駕駛通常整合在許多現有應用程式中，並可協助完成常見任務，例如使用生成式人工智慧模型。
你可能已經看過這種模式了。
聊天面板會在你的工作旁邊打開，幫助你利用目前產品中的上下文資訊來撰寫、總結或創建內容。思考一下副駕駛背後的生命週期也很有幫助。
首先，使用大量資料來訓練大型語言模型。
然後，像 Azure OpenAI 這樣的服務會將這些預訓練模型提供給開發者，開發者可以直接使用它們，也可以使用自訂資料微調。
模型部署完成後，即可供應用程式使用。然後，開發人員建立副駕駛體驗，向模型提交提示，並塑造真實工作流程的輸出。
最後，商業用戶利用這些輔助工具來提高生產力和創造力，幫助完成初稿、綜合資訊、支援規劃等等。
接下來，讓我們專注於直接影響你與任何副駕駛日常合作成功的事情——快速工程。
提示工程是指建立提示以獲得更好結果的流程。
而且它不僅適用於開發人員。任何使用生成式人工智慧應用程式的人都可以透過使用清晰的語言、設定預期、提供範例以及將請求建立在相關數據之上來提高回應品質。
一種方法是使用直接的語言，明確說明你想要的回應類型。例如，列出八月在愛丁堡可以做的 10 件事。
另一種方法是使用系統訊息，在其中描述助手應該如何提問，例如「您是一位樂於助人的助手，以愉快、友好的方式回應」。
你還提供了範例。
即使 LLM 可以進行零樣本學習（即沒有範例），但透過給它一個範例回應（例如「在雲到來之前，早上參觀城堡」），你可以使用單樣本或少樣本學習來獲得更一致的結果。
並讓該模型繼續沿用這種風格。
最後，接地數據為模型提供了上下文，使其能夠產生更準確的輸出。
例如，如果您想要一封電子郵件的摘要，請在提示中包含電子郵件正文，並要求模型對其進行總結。總的來說，回覆的品質不僅取決於模型，還取決於你如何傳達你的目標和限制條件。因此，清晰明確的提示會產生顯著的效果。
讓我們快速總結一下第一個模組所涵蓋的內容。
生成式人工智慧通常內建於軟體應用程式中，並使用基於海量文字訓練的大型語言模型來產生類似人類的自然語言回應。在某些情況下，甚至是原始影像。
你現在擁有了必需品。什麼是生成式 AI，大型語言模型的作用，什麼是 Azure Open AI，什麼是 Copilots，以及快速工程如何幫助您改善所獲得的回應。
現在，我們將從人工智慧基礎轉向本學習路徑中專門關注的安全領域——微軟安全助理。在這裡，我們將了解它是什麼、它是如何運作的、您將在整個產品中看到的術語，以及在組織中啟用它需要什麼。
在本模組中，您將熟悉 Microsoft Security Copilot。我們將從基本術語開始，然後逐步介紹 Security Copilot 如何處理提示、什麼因素使提示有效，以及如何啟用解決方案以便使用者可以開始使用它。
到最後，您將能夠描述 Microsoft Security Copilot 是什麼，解釋 Security Copilot 的關鍵術語，解釋它如何處理提示請求，識別有效提示的要素，並描述如何在您的組織中啟用 Microsoft Security Copilot。
Microsoft Security Copilot 是一款基於人工智慧的雲端安全分析工具，可以幫助像我們這樣的分析人員快速回應威脅，以機器速度處理訊號，並比其他方式更快地評估暴露的風險。
換句話說，它的設計目的是幫助您從原始安全資料轉化為可操作的理解，而無需浪費時間進行手動綜合。
安全副駕駛結合了強大的大型語言模型和來自微軟的安全專用模型。
它整合了微軟和非微軟的資源，並以機器速度進行學習，以幫助分析人員識別和應對新出現的威脅。
同樣重要的是，企業資料受到全面的企業合規和安全控制措施的保護。因此，您可以在不影響治理預期的前提下應用人工智慧輔助。
現在，讓我們來看看安全副駕駛的核心用例。它的設計宗旨是讓一切變得簡單。
一個常見的應用場景是事件總結，利用生成式人工智慧將複雜的警報提煉成簡潔可操作的摘要。
這有助於您快速了解情況，並在整個組織內進行清晰的溝通，從而加快速度並做出更好的決策。
另一個場景是影響分析，其中 AI 驅動的分析可幫助您評估事件的潛在影響，突出顯示受影響的系統和數據，以便您可以優先處理回應工作。第三種情況是對腳本進行逆向工程。 Copilot 無需手動解包複雜或混淆的命令列腳本，即可將腳本翻譯成自然語言，並解釋正在執行的操作，同時還能幫助您提取腳本中找到的指標並將其連結到環境中的實體。最後，指導性因應措施為分診、調查、遏制和補救提供了循序漸進的建議。通常包含深度鏈接，幫助您更快地採取行動。
讓我們來看看如何體驗安全副駕駛功能。一種方法是透過專門網站提供的獨立體驗。在這種體驗中，您可以透過提示欄進行交互，以自然語言提交請求，Copilot 會以文字、圖像或文件的形式傳回輸出。
也需要將此與嵌入式體驗進行對比，在嵌入式體驗中，Copilot 的功能直接置於 Microsoft 安全性產品中。接下來我們將探討這一點，因為嵌入式 Copilot 通常是分析的起點，也是調查已經開始的地方。
微軟的一些產品，例如 Microsoft Defender XDR，將 Copilot 直接嵌入到使用者介面中。在 Defender XDR 中，事件和進階搜尋等領域是嵌入式 Copilot 可以發揮作用的例子。這個想法很簡單。您無需離開目前使用的工具即可開始使用人工智慧輔助的摘要、指導或分析。你從現在的位置出發，Copilot 可以幫助你更快前進。
在你開始寫提示之前（哼），讓我們先統一一下你在《安全副駕駛》中會看到的一些術語。
會話是指 Copilot 中的一次特定對話，Copilot 會在該會話中維護上下文。提示是指透過提示欄在會話中輸入的特定語句或問題。
能力是 Copilot 用於解決部分問題的功能，您可能還會聽到能力被稱為技能。
外掛程式是由特定資源（例如 Microsoft Intune）提供的一系列功能的集合。而協調器則是 Copilot 的系統，用於將這些功能組合在一起以回應您的提示。
體驗的核心是提示列。你可以用它來告訴 Copilot 你想從安全資料中獲得哪些洞見。在後台，Copilot 透過外掛程式與各種來源集成，包括 Microsoft 安全產品（如 Microsoft Sentinel、Microsoft Defender XDR、Microsoft Intune）以及非 Microsoft 解決方案和開源情報來源。對於每個資料來源，該插件都提供了一系列功能，每個功能都旨在執行該產品範圍內的特定任務。
以下是一個具體的例子。 Microsoft Defender XDR 外掛程式支援分析檔案、產生事件報告、產生引導式回應、列出事件和相關警報以及總結裝置安全狀態等功能。當你提出問題時，協調器可以選擇並組合這些功能，以便提供的回應不僅僅是一些通用的文字答案，而是基於你的安全工具和資料。
現在，讓我們把寫作提示變成實際操作。
安全分析師和研究人員在編寫有效的提示時應包含四個要素。目標、背景、預期和來源。您的目標是取得您需要的特定安全相關資訊。
請說明你為什麼需要它或你將如何使用它。
期望決定了格式或目標受眾，例如你想要的是要點清單、簡短摘要，還是為高階主管撰寫的報告。而資料來源是指 Copilot 應該使用的已知資訊資料來源或外掛程式。
編寫提示時，請記住以下幾點。
要具體、簡潔。
迭代。如果第一個回覆未能完全滿足您的需求，請嘗試其他版本的提示。
提供必要的背景信息，以縮小 Copilot 的搜尋範圍。
給予正面的指示，而不是專注於不要做什麼，並直接以「你」的身份與副駕駛對話，以使請求清晰且可操作。
現在，讓我們一起來看看如何啟用 Microsoft Security Copilot。
要開始使用該服務，組織需要對服務和使用者進行註冊。
實際上，您只需導覽至 Security Copilot 網站，選擇一個 Azure 訂閱，然後選擇或建立安全資源群組。
然後，您可以透過命名容量並新增至少一個 SCU（安全計算單元）來配置 Copilot 容量。之後，您需要設定預設環境並指派相應的角色權限。
接下來將更詳細地探討這些步驟。
在使用 Copilot 之前，管理員需要配置和分配容量。
您必須擁有 Azure 訂閱，並且必須是 Azure 擁有者，或至少是資源群組層級的 Azure 參與者。
一個重要的細微差別是，全域管理員預設不會自動成為 Azure 擁有者或參與者。
此存取權限可在 Azure 入口網站中進行設定。
提供容量有兩種方式。您可以在 Security Copilot 中設定容量（建議方法），也可以透過 Azure 入口網站設定容量。一旦容量到位，Security Copilot 也會為容量所有者提供使用情況監控儀表板，以便您可以追蹤消耗並管理容量的分配方式。
容量配置完成後，即可設定預設環境。為此，您需要以下 Microsoft Entra ID 角色之一：全域管理員或安全性管理員。
在 [snorts] 設定過程中，系統會提示您配置幾個設置，包括要分配多少 SCU 安全運算單元容量以及租用戶的地理位置，因為該服務收集的客戶資料儲存在該區域。
Security Copilot 在 Azure 資料中心運行，涵蓋多個區域，包括歐盟、英國、美國、澳洲、紐西蘭、日本、加拿大和南美洲。您也可以決定是否選擇加入或退出資料共享。
產品改進方案。
例如，您可以允許 Microsoft 從 Security Copilot 擷取數據，並使用人工審核來驗證產品效能，或允許擷取資料並進行人工審核，以協助建立和驗證 Microsoft 安全 AI 模型。
重要的是，選擇加入並不會允許微軟使用客戶資料來訓練基礎模型。
另一個關鍵設定控制 Security Copilot 是否可以存取來自 Microsoft 365 服務的資料。如果關閉此選項，您的組織將無法使用存取 Microsoft 365 服務的外掛程式。
目前，使用 Microsoft Purview 外掛程式需要啟用此選項。
更改此設定需要具有全域管理員角色的使用者。
現在，讓我們來明確一下權限問題。您可以使用 Microsoft Entra ID 角色或 Security Copilot 角色指派存取權限。最佳實踐是使用權限最小的角色，同時又能使用戶能夠完成所需的工作。
Microsoft Entra 角色（如全域管理員、安全性管理員、安全性操作員和安全讀取器）不僅適用於 Copilot。因此，它們授予租戶更廣泛的權限。
為了使 Copilot 存取權限更具針對性，安全性 Copilot 還引入了兩個角色，其功能類似於存取群組，但由 Copilot 本身進行管理。
Copilot 所有者和 Copilot 貢獻者。
這些角色僅授予對安全副駕駛功能的存取權限。
Microsoft Entra 中的安全性管理員和全域管理員角色會自動繼承 Copilot 擁有者存取權限。預設情況下，Entra 租用戶中的所有使用者都擁有 Copilot 貢獻者存取權限。
這意味著任何擁有授權租用戶的使用者都可以建立會話並執行提示符，除非管理員透過從工作區參與者指派中刪除所有使用者並將其替換為特定的安全性群組來限制存取權限。
還有一點要注意，Copilot 並不會超出你已經擁有的存取權限。
即使您可以開啟 Copilot 並建立提示，單一外掛程式也可能需要額外的產品特定角色。例如，要使用 Microsoft Sentinel 插件，您需要像讀者這樣的 Sentinel 角色才能存取工作區中的事件。
要使用 Intune 裝置和策略插件，您需要一個 Intune 特定角色，例如端點安全管理員。在許多情況下，微軟外掛程式採用代表模式。 Copilot 可以識別許可並代表您登入產品，無論插件是否啟用；但有些插件需要額外的設定和參數進行身份驗證。
讓我們總結一下本模組的內容。
Microsoft Security Copilot 是一款以人工智慧為基礎的雲端安全分析工具，旨在協助組織應對日益嚴峻的網路安全挑戰。
您將了解什麼是 Security Copilot、關鍵術語、如何透過外掛程式和功能處理提示請求、什麼使提示有效，以及啟用 Security Copilot 的實際步驟，包括容量、環境設定和角色權限。
接下來，我們將重點放在嵌入式體驗，其中 Security Copilot 可以直接從 Microsoft 安全產品存取。這很重要，因為它將人工智慧助理直接引入調查人員的工作流程中，減少了上下文切換，從而能夠更快地做出決策。
可以透過某些微軟安全產品直接存取 Microsoft Security Copilot，這就是我們所說的嵌入式體驗。
在本模組中，我們將了解微軟安全解決方案中嵌入式體驗所支援的場景。在本模組結束時，您將能夠描述 Microsoft Defender XDR、Microsoft Purview 和 Microsoft Entra 中的 Microsoft Copilot。
在這裡，我們將重點放在嵌入式概念上。微軟安全助理（Microsoft Security Copilot）可直接從部分微軟安全產品（如 Defender XDR、Microsoft Entra 和 Purview）訪問，未來還將整合更多產品。在嵌入式體驗中，Copilot 直接引入了特定於產品的功能，這可以提高處理效率，因為 Security Copilot 可以立即獲得正確的工具和上下文。嵌入式體驗也是進行安全調查的絕佳切入點。
當您需要進行更深入的跨產品調查時，您可以無縫過渡到獨立體驗，以引入為您的角色啟用的所有 Copilot 功能。
若要使用嵌入式體驗，必須啟用該解決方案的 Microsoft 插件，且使用者必須有存取 Copilot 的權限。此外，還需要存取底層產品和資料所需的任何其他權限。
讓我們來看一個關鍵的例子。
Security Copilot 已嵌入 Microsoft Defender XDR 中。此次整合旨在幫助安全團隊快速且有效率地調查和應對安全事件。
在 Defender XDR 中，Copilot 可以支援以下功能：事件摘要、提供引導式回應、腳本分析、將自然語言轉換為 KQL 查詢以進行進階搜尋、產生事件報告、分析檔案和裝置摘要。
當您需要快速了解事件時，Defender XDR 中的 Copilot 可以產生事件摘要。 Copilot 會產生攻擊概覽，幫助您快速了解發生了什麼、涉及哪些資產以及攻擊的時間軸。事實上，當您導覽至事件頁面時，Copilot 會自動建立摘要。最多可將包含 100 個警報的事件匯總成一個事件摘要。根據可用數據，摘要可以包括攻擊開始的時間、攻擊開始的地點（即涉及的實體或資產）、攻擊展開的時間線、涉及的資產、入侵指標，甚至涉及的威脅行為者的名稱。其價值立竿見影。
您可以減少閱讀原始警報詳情的時間，將更多時間用於做出明智的應對決策。
另一個強大的功能是引導回應。 Defender XDR 中的 Copilot 使用人工智慧和機器學習來分析事件背景，並從先前的調查中學習，從而產生您可以遵循的適當回應。這有助於各級緊急應變團隊自信、快速地採取應變措施。
引導式回答分為不同的類別。分診包括將事件分類為資訊性事件、真陽性事件和假陽性事件的建議。
遏制措施是指採取措施控制事件發展。調查結果表明，下一步需要收集更多證據，補救措施的重點是針對事件中涉及的特定實體採取的應對行動。
每張指導回應卡都包含詳細信息，例如建議採取該行動的原因，並且可能包含查看類似事件等選項，以幫助您從各種環境中的模式中學習。
對於補救措施，當需要採取密碼重設等步驟時，團隊也可以查看使用者資訊。
許多複雜的攻擊，包括勒索軟體攻擊，都使用腳本和 PowerShell 來逃避偵測。而且這些腳本通常經過混淆處理，導致分析速度慢且容易出錯。
Defender XDR 中的 Copilot 腳本分析功能可協助您在不依賴外部工具的情況下檢查腳本和程式碼，從而減少摩擦。您可以從事件中的警報時間軸存取腳本分析。特別是對於包含腳本或程式碼的時間軸條目，例如 PowerShell.exe 事件，Copilot 支援 PowerShell、批次、bash 等腳本語言。這樣就能更快了解腳本的運作機制，並且更快地判斷它是惡意的還是良性的。
威脅狩獵通常需要編寫 KQL 查詢，如果您是該語言的新手或想要快速上手，這可能會成為一個障礙。 Defender XDR 中的 Copilot 包含進階搜尋查詢助理功能，可減少從頭開始編寫搜尋查詢所需的時間。您可以根據建議的提示產生 KQL 查詢，也可以用自然語言輸入自己的提示，例如要求與特定使用者相關的所有警報。
Copilot 接著產生與進階查詢模式一致的 KQL 查詢。
從那裡，您可以直接執行查詢，也可以將其插入編輯器中進行最佳化、儲存、共用或稍後運行。
這樣一來，您就可以專注於調查威脅，而不是糾結於文法問題。
接下來，我們將從調查轉向記錄。
在 Microsoft Defender XDR 中，Copilot 只需執行一個操作即可產生完整的事件報告。
選擇省略號或報告圖標，您可以讓 Copilot 產生事件報告，匯總事件生命週期中發生的一切。其中包括事件管理行動的關鍵時間戳記、參與回應的分析人員、事件的分類方式以及採取的調查和補救措施。
它還記錄了後續行動、建議和下一步措施。
事件摘要可讓您快速了解發生了什麼，而事件報告則提供全面的可審計記錄，其中包含分析師驅動的步驟、自動化操作以及來自 Defender XDR 和 Microsoft Sentinel 的支援上下文。
讓我們來看看 Copilot 如何幫助文件分析。
複雜的攻擊通常依賴與合法文件或系統文件高度相似的文件來逃避偵測。 Microsoft Defender XDR 中的 Copilot 功能可讓安全團隊快速識別可疑或惡意文件，而無需手動深入挖掘原始細節。
當您分析檔案時，Copilot 會產生一個概述，評估檔案的行為和風險級別，以及一個詳細部分，其中包括嵌入字串、API 呼叫和相關憑證等內容。
這使得分析人員能夠迅速從不確定性走向明確，並決定該文件是否構成真正的威脅。
另一項有價值的功能是設備資訊匯總。
Copilot 可以產生裝置安全狀況的簡明摘要，包括易受攻擊的軟體、暴露等級以及觀察到的任何異常行為。安全分析師可以利用此設備摘要，透過了解事件中涉及設備的更廣泛背景，加快調查速度。
無論是直接從事件資產視圖存取還是從設備概覽頁面訪問，摘要都能幫助團隊快速確定設備是否對環境構成更大的風險。
在所有這些 Defender XDR 功能中，有一些功能始終保持不變。一是反饋。與獨立體驗一樣，嵌入式體驗可讓您對 AI 產生的回應提供回饋，無論這些回應看起來是否準確、偏離目標或可能不恰當。
這些回饋有助於提高 Copilot 回應的整體品質和可靠性。
另一個共同的能力是從嵌入式體驗過渡到獨立體驗的能力。
嵌入式 Copilot 是一個很棒的調查起點，尤其是當您已經在 Defender XDR 中工作時。
如果您的調查範圍擴大，需要進行更深入的跨產品分析，您可以無縫過渡到獨立體驗，並繼續使用為您的角色啟用的全部 Copilot 功能。
現在，讓我們來介紹 Copilot 安全功能的另一個強大擴充功能——Microsoft Defender 中的 Copilot 代理程式。
這些代理程式可透過 Defender 入口網站中的安全商店獲取，旨在協助自動化和加速常見的安全操作任務。
在 Microsoft Defender 入口網站中，安全商店提供了由 Microsoft 及其合作夥伴發布的不斷增長的代理程式集合。這些代理程式直接整合到 Microsoft Defender 中，並執行事件分類、調查、威脅搜尋和威脅情報等任務。每個代理商都是專門設計的，旨在減少人工操作，幫助 SOC 團隊更有效率地運作。在本模組結束時，您將能夠描述 Microsoft Defender 中可用的安全性 Copilot AI 代理，並了解它們如何支援現實世界的安全操作工作流程。
讓我們仔細看看目前有哪些代理人。
若要從安全商店購買和部署自訂代理，您需要具有 SCU 功能的安全副駕駛工作區存取權。
釣魚事件分類代理程式可幫助安全分析師自動對使用者提交的釣魚事件進行分類和分級。它可自主運行，當使用者舉報釣魚郵件時就會觸發。
此代理程式需要 Microsoft Defender 端點計畫二和安全性管理員權限才能進行設定。
威脅情報簡報代理人透過收集和綜合來自多個來源的信息，提供定期客製化的威脅情報簡報。
它能夠自主運行，幫助團隊專注於相關的威脅，而無需人工研究。
威脅狩獵代理人使用自然語言協助分析人員進行端到端的威脅狩獵。它不僅可以產生 KQL 查詢，還可以解釋結果、揭示見解，並引導分析師完成整個搜尋過程。
最後，Dynamics 威脅偵測代理程式是一個始終在線的後端服務，它會持續地在 Defender 和 Microsoft Sentinel 中尋找隱藏的威脅。它利用人工智慧將警報、事件、異常和威脅情報關聯起來，以發現漏報和偵測漏洞。
這裡我們重點介紹漁業分類代理的實際操作。部署後，該代理會自動評估使用者提交的釣魚訊息，分析指標，並對事件進行分類。透過將常規的漁業分析工作交給自主代理，SOC 團隊可以減少警報疲勞，並將時間集中用於影響更大的調查。
現在，讓我們花點時間看看安全副駕駛是如何運作的。我們一起來看一個示範。
在這個示範中，我們來設定 Microsoft Security Copilot。
我們首先要做的是授予管理員管理該服務本身所需的權限。
所以，我們將在 Azure 中設定權限來實現這一點。
我們開始吧。
我們現在正在 Azure 入口網站中。
我們將開啟 Entra ID，然後在 Entra ID 中，向下捲動至管理，並啟用 Azure 資源的存取管理。
我們會為霍華德·艾弗里做這件事。
好了，我們完成了。
讓我們[嗤之以鼻]退出 Azure 門戶，然後選擇我們的訂閱，以確保 Howard Avery 現在不僅擁有管理 Entra ID 的必要權限，而且擁有設定和配置 Security Copilot 的必要權限。
所以，從訂閱設定中，我們將點擊存取控制，也就是身分和存取管理。
接下來我們來設定角色分配。
我們來新增角色分配。
哪個角色？
我們需要擁有管理員權限才能執行此操作。所以，我們讓艾弗里·霍華德擔任老闆吧。
這是一個非常自由的角色。所以，和往常一樣，如果可以的話，越嚴格越好。接下來，我們來選擇誰來擔任這個角色。通常情況下，我們會選擇一個群組，但為了演示，我將選擇一個使用者。我們還是選擇艾佛瑞‧霍華德吧。
我們將給予艾弗里·霍華德充分的權力來扮演這個角色。
允許使用者指派除管理員權限之外的所有角色。所以，我們將取消這項權限，但艾佛瑞霍華德目前擁有所有其他可用的管理權限。
[嗤笑] 我們差不多完成了。
現在，讓我們來設定 Microsoft Security Copilot 的容量。我們已經授予艾弗里·霍華德執行此操作所需的必要權限。現在，身為 Avery，讓我們先選擇要使用的 Azure 訂閱、資源群組以及要預配服務的位置。
我們將給這個容量取個名字。我們將沿用預設設定。你想把它部署在哪裡？我們將選擇美國作為本次演示的目標國家。但是，如果該地區業務繁忙，我們將允許 Copilot 擴展到其他地區。
如果這無法接受，如果 Copilot 必須停留在您的區域內（無論是什麼區域），那麼請不要選擇該選項。
我們選擇的容量區域是美國東部。最後，我們需要配備多少台設備？
我們先從第一個開始。這是我們事後可以調整的。
最後，我們還可以啟用動態使用功能。因此，如果超過我們一個單位的產能，我們可以在需要時使用覆蓋單位，現在我們可以開始按需使用產能了。
我們需要的話，每單位6美元。
您可以隨時開啟或關閉此功能。
最後，關於按需單元，我們是要限制其數量，還是要讓 Copilot 根據需要擴展到任何層級？讓我們接受並確認我們理解這些條款和條件，然後開始提供容量。
我們真的想把遙測數據寄給微軟嗎？ （嗤笑）我讓你自己選擇。
您的資訊絕不會用於訓練模型。
正如這裡提到的，我們絕不會使用客戶資訊來訓練我們的人工智慧模型。
最後，您是否希望將 Microsoft Purview 整合到您的安全性 Copilot 中？不妨。此外，我們也要授予屬於 Purview Entra ID 和 Azure 中的安全性群組、標準安全群組的使用者存取權限，以便他們也能使用安全性 Copilot。讓我們啟用建議的 Microsoft 安全性角色。
我們繼續。
一切就緒。我們已部署安全助手。
我們已經準備好開始使用它了。
我們將先了解互動式體驗，然後再了解嵌入式體驗。
在我們開始使用互動式體驗之前，我們可以看到安全副駕駛會給我們一些提示，讓我們來探索。
讓我們點擊左上角的漢堡菜單按鈕。這裡面有很多好東西，我想在正式開始之前先和你們一起探索一下。這是你的主頁連結。你的會話就在這裡。您與安全副駕駛的任何對話都將被保存，您可以隨時返回查看。
從這裡，我們還有提示簿庫，其中包含您可以直接使用的預先建置提示，您還可以定義自己的提示簿來執行一系列提示，我們還可以對我們的提示簿進行參數化。
稍後我們會看到一個例子，但現在讓我們進入設定。這些是我們的個人設定。
這裡列出了我們正在使用的安全運算單元的數量、名稱、我們先前設定的容量、我們的訂閱、我們的資源群組，如有必要，我們可以更改這些資訊。
我們這次演示中不會這樣做。
這就是我們的總計算單元，如有必要，我們可以對其進行更改。
我們還可以開啟或關閉是否向微軟發送遙測數據，以及是否將安全輔助駕駛與 Purview 整合。
就維持現狀吧。
最後，以下列出了哪些使用者可以向安全副駕駛上傳檔案。目前，我們遇到的問題是「任何人都無法上傳文件」。我們就保持原樣。
接下來是插件。這就是你從副駕駛獲得很多力量的地方。您可以在這裡啟用或停用各種插件。目前，我們只能存取 Microsoft 365 服務中的資料。它還沒有開機，但我們只需單擊一下就能打開它，一切就緒。
我們還可以控制誰可以管理插件。目前，我們暫且將其設為僅限所有者使用。
角色分配：誰有權存取安全副駕駛？
目前，我們有三個角色可以存取安全副駕駛。我們可以新增其他成員，或只需點擊一下即可新增推薦角色。這將添加所有在 Entra ID 角色、Purview 角色和 Defender 角色中負責安全的所有人員。他們現在將可以使用安全副駕駛功能。
讓我們來看看使用情況監控。
這裡很重要。你想充分利用副駕駛功能。那麼，根據我們提供的容量，該服務的使用情況如何？誰在使用這項服務？我們可以看到這裡的用戶以及他們對安全副駕駛的使用情況。讓我們來看看設定。這是為了我們的舒適和便利，我們可以選擇想要使用的主題、工作區環境，以及您想要使用的語言（法語、英語，或任何您想要的語言）。以下是我們的隱私權聲明。我再次重申，我們不會利用您的資訊來改善我們的人工智慧服務。
好了，我們回家吧，然後實際使用安全副駕駛功能。
我們可以嘗試一些提示。下方是提示框。
您可以在這裡輸入自然語言提示和查詢。
它運用了生成式人工智慧技術。它使用大型語言模型。所以，你的提示中不需要使用任何特定的形式或結構。用自然語言表達自己。
還可以查看預先定義的提示，以了解我們可以與安全副駕駛進行哪些類型的交互，例如自然語言交互。
例如，這裡有一個提示。應用程式名稱屬於哪個群組？目前Sentinel事件的關鍵點是什麼？我們可以點擊它們。例如，如果我們選擇套用名稱所屬的群組，那麼套用名稱將會是一個參數。我們會輸入想要查看的應用程式的名稱。
好的，我們打開提示本。
讓我們來看看提示本是如何運作的。
這裡[嗤之以鼻]提示簿是一組預先定義的、可執行的提示的集合。
它們通常是參數化的。在這種情況下，我會指定演員的姓名。然後，我們在提示手冊中看到的每一個提示都會被執行。我們稍後會看到一個例子。
有很多提示書。我強烈建議你去探索一下這些內容。
它們按角色分類，例如 SOC 分析師、IT 管理員、資料安全管理員，這將篩選你的提示書。
回到會話環節，如果您同時處理多個案件，這將非常有價值。不要把它們都放在同一個對話裡，另開一個會話。
讓我們打開之前的會話。以下是我們之前與 Security Copilot 的對話，我們當時問道：「最近三次登入失敗的記錄是什麼？」 我們可以看到最後三次登入失敗，從你這裡的心形圖示開始。
嗯，又是同一個使用者。
又是同一個用戶。用戶登入失敗三次。現在我們要問的是，「登入失敗的 UPN 是什麼？」 Copilot 為我們提供了一個清晰的使用者主體名稱清單。所以，使用自然語言，提出問題，讓它為你產生一個回應[嗤笑]。
然後，你可以把這些資訊輸入到電子表格中。你可以讓 Copilot 給你一個表格、一個項目符號，或任何你想要的輸出結果。以上是安全副駕駛互動體驗的概述。現在，讓我們來看看安全助理（Security Copilot）的嵌入式體驗。
所以，我們體驗了互動式副駕駛功能。現在，讓我們換個角度，來看看嵌入式體驗，現在當您在 Defender 中進行調查時，Copilot 會自動啟動。我們來看一起發生在我們這邊的事件。發動了人為操作的勒索軟體攻擊。這令人擔憂。我們來做一些調查。
打開事件報告後，請注意右側，副駕駛會立即提供事件的簡要概述。
找到了。我不會通讀全文，但其中包含攻擊事件的描述以及關於如何進行分類、如何處理用戶、如何聯繫受影響用戶、如何對事件進行分類等建議，都非常實用。
目前，我們將把該事件標記為已完成，並繼續使用嵌入式體驗，看看 Copilot 能為我們做些什麼。我們將查看一個特定的警報，即可疑的 RDP 會話，當我們選擇該警報時，Copilot 再次啟動並提供了一個很好的警報摘要。
包括我們在這裡看到的令人擔憂的橫向移動。
讓我們更詳細地看一下這條警報。我們將打開警報頁面。
我們可以看到流程樹。我們可以看到涉事設備。讓我們使用 Copilot 來提供該設備的概要資訊。
開始了。讓我們把它擴展一下。
以下是 Copilot 提供給我們的摘要。
我們將關閉它。
我們也可以用使用者帳戶 Jonathan Wolcott 執行相同的操作。讓我們總結一下他們的資訊。
再一次，訊息直接來自副駕駛。
我們就此結束吧。
接下來我們來看看流程樹。
查看是什麼觸發了警報。我們會擴大它的範圍。
向下滾動一點。哦，這裡還有一些 PowerShell 的東西在用。我們可以看到 PowerShell 執行了一個腳本。這讓我有點擔心。那是一台終端用戶機器。他們為什麼要執行 PowerShell 腳本？
以下是執行的腳本。
如果你會讀懂 PowerShell 程式碼，那就太好了。如果你不懂如何閱讀 PowerShell 程式碼，沒關係。
讓我們讓 Copilot 來幫我們分析一下腳本。下面用簡單易懂的英文一步一步解釋一下腳本的功能。這裡最棒的地方在於，即使腳本被混淆了，Copilot 也會為我們解密，並向我們解釋它的作用。這裡有一些相關的活動。以下是副駕駛逐行解釋的內容。我們可以看到劇本的台詞。
我們也可以看到腳本中使用的 MITRE 技術，例如原生 API 呼叫。或者再往下，我們還有一個系統資訊發現功能。所以，我不需要會讀劇本。副駕駛幫我完成了大部分繁重的工作。所以，作為安全營運分析師，我現在可以妥善處理並調查該事件了。
Copilot 還能幫助我們理解文件，不僅是腳本，還有攻擊中可能使用的文件。好，我們來看看。讓我們深入剖析證據和回應。文件。這些是用戶電腦上以 Mimikatz 開頭的可疑檔案。 Mimikatz到底是什麼鬼？好，讓我們來深入探討一下，讓 Copilot 為我們解釋一下。
我們點選省略號。
上傳文件並產生文件分析報告。 Copilot 告訴我們偵測到了檔案 Mimikatz.exe，它是一個惡意軟體。
它是一種用於繞過安全資訊捕獲的工具。
副駕駛功能可以實現這一點。那麼，讓我們繼續調查。
現在，讓我們來做一些 KQL 操作。
無論您是 KQL 高手還是新手，讓我們切換到互動式安全 Copilot 體驗。
接下來，我們將請 Copilot 使用對話式的簡單語言來幫助我們進一步進行調查。
所以，與其讓我們自己去摸索一切，不如讓我們使用提示手冊來啟動我們的調查。
我們將使用 Microsoft 365 Defender 事件調查功能。
我們需要提供一個參數，就是 Defender 事件 ID。
如果我沒記錯的話，那是185856年。提交。現在，互動式體驗中的安全助理將調出我調查該事件所需的所有詳細資訊。
找到了。有很多可操作的細節，還在仔細分析。
現在，我看到了一些非常有趣的東西。我需要密切注意的事情。所以，我會選擇結果並置頂。
所以，現在它們可以在右邊找到了。我可以收集與我的調查相關的證據和信息，並將這些證據分享給我的團隊。因此，我們可以共同努力處理這起事件。我現在不打算分享，但這是分享按鈕，你可以點擊。
最後，讓我們使用 Security Copilot 來幫助我們進行查詢。請幫我們解決KQL問題。
嗯，KQL 需要一些專業知識才能編寫查詢，我們將在本課程的後面部分學習 KQL，但現在，讓我們使用 Copilot 來幫助我們用自然語言產生 KQL 查詢。好了。根據事件情況，建立查詢以主動搜尋惡意軟體攻擊類型。
讓我們提交提示。
讓我們讓 Copilot 為我們產生一個查詢。
應該不會花太長時間。
好了。以下是 Copilot 為我們產生的查詢語句，並附有完整文件。這看起來可能有點嚇人。如果需要，可以請副駕駛逐行解釋給你聽。
但現在，我們先來試試看。我們去打獵吧。
或者我們直接查看日誌吧。
把 cool pilot 為我們產生的查詢語句填入這裡。
然後運行它。
這就是我們的結果。因此，我們無需編寫任何一行 KQL 程式碼即可產生複雜的查詢。
如果您需要有關查詢的更多詳細信息，或者需要跟進查詢以了解或更改查詢，請返回交互式酷炫飛行員體驗，並讓酷炫飛行員幫助您修改查詢。添加、修改，隨你所需。
現在我們已經看到了安全酷炫試點專案的互動式和嵌入式體驗，我們也看到瞭如何在我們的工作流程中使用生成式人工智慧來幫助我們處理和理解 Sentinel 中的事件、警報和事故。
讓我們總結一下第二條學習路徑。在本學習路徑中，您探索如何透過嵌入式體驗直接從 Microsoft 安全產品存取 Microsoft 安全性酷炫試點專案。
您學習如何在 Microsoft Defender XDR、Microsoft Purview 和 Microsoft Entra 中描述 Microsoft 安全性酷炫試點。
以及這種整合如何幫助安全團隊更有效率地調查和應對威脅。
我們的會議到此結束。繼續學習之旅的方式有很多種。
我們鼓勵您觀看本課程中的其他視頻，或在 Microsoft Learn (aka.ms/learn) 上搜尋您下一個感興趣的主題。